ce qui est intéressant papa il va très
bien mais c'est que je crois que tu n'as
pas d'enfant moi non plus c'est que tu
vieillis tu te dis où va aller le peu
d'argent qu'on a quand même oh non on
peut se positionner et ben crois pas si
bien dire moi moi ça devrait aller de
mon père maintenant il a déjà fait sa
vie donc maintenant à ma sœur ça monte
d'abord tu as pas d'enfants et après
c'est les collatéraux ta sœur mais si
jamais ne veut ils vont payer 60 %
d'impôts bref ça va être pour l'État
mais je me suis quand même posé la
question donc j'étais voir un notaire
Julie qu'est-ce que je fais j'ai ça
qu'est-ce que je fais donc il m'a dit
faites un testament tu as quoi tu vois
des bricoles
pas grand chose mais faites comme un
testament pour que tout n'aille pas
peut-être à l'état voilà
écoute-moi bien il m'a dit il y a deux
testament possible il y a le testament
de raison péter les cousins la famine et
le testament du cœur ah il m'a dit le
testament du cœur je vous fais le
testament du cul aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non le 2 coeur c'est si tu y vas
vraiment vraiment avec les gens qui ont
compté pour toi et que tu veux vraiment
que tu veux vraiment protéger tu verras
que à ton âge tu n'arrives pas à 10
personnes quoi
je suis arrivé à neuf non on était
personne
que de l'argent tu peux donner aussi à
quelque chose
à vous je vous file du pognon parce que
on peut laisser un souvenir une montre
une bague un truc voilà
alors il faut pas dire ça porte malheur
je ne veux pas mourir je vous ai laissé
quelque chose mais c'est pas de l'argent
ah d'accord il s'en fout du coup
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vais voir me déplacer
non mais ça va mon chien me faire chier
plus qu'autre chose non mais ça la
traîné dans le coffre de la voiture
laisse tomber oublie-moi voilà
oublie-moi
tu as pas une voiture sinon
vulgaire non mais t'inquiète pas
donc je peux vulgaire avec vous oui
alors pardon la deuxième de voiture
et on les gars j'ai mis Cyril parce
qu'il a compté pour moi il m'a aidé
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait pour moi
aussi c'était toujours
soutenu
toi tu l'as gris toi qui toi
on peut pas déshériter les enfants on
peut pas déshériter
moi je les ai prévenu
de réserve la réserve c'est ses immenses
personnalités les grands patrons les
machins qui disent par exemple Bill
Gates il a dit moi je donnerais à peine
je crois que c'est plus 1% de ma fortune
à mes enfants parce qu'il faut qu'il se
débrouille par eux-mêmes vous allez
faire ça vous pour leur dire
[Rires]
lui attention à lui il travaille tout le
temps il pige partout il est à la télé
j'ai même pas des à la télé qu'il y
était déjà il dépense pas un euro c'est
une part international c'est une barre
de ferme c'est un arbre c'est du chêne
le garçon
fortinés
ailleurs vous m'arrêtez au bout de trois
jours
tu as travaillé et il a commencé la télé
avant nous tous frère c'est un truc de
ouf mais je le voyais à la télé moi je
le regardais je n'ai pas de télé je le
voyais et je pouvais pas le blairer hein
je te jure je le regardais j'avais envie
mais je pouvais pas le blairer mais non
mais je me rappelle il avait une coupe
comme ça il payait les émissions de foot
je pouvais pas le virer le procureur
j'avais envie de le défoncer mais je le
regarde
mais je le regardais parce qu'il bon
c'est pour ça que vous m'avez recruté
dans la vous m'avez croisé dans la rue
et après non et au début je l'ai pas et
après je me suis fait à lui
[Musique]
veut pas dire c'est pas des fortunes
mais c'est c'est correct quoi
tu penses que tu auras quelque chose
pour ma personne si demain
si demain ça devait mal se passer pour
toi sans hésiter la vérité bien sûr que
oui bien sûr que oui quelque chose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant ah non mais c'est vrai tu as
pas un truc pour moi non mais pense à
moi une petite somme ça sert à rien pour
vous si ça sert si je voulais quand même
une petite somme ah merci vous aurez
beaucoup d'impôts dessus ça vous arrange
non mais t'emmerde pas avec ça
depuis hier j'ai regardé la télévision
et des rediffusion
chacun travaillait bien sûr mais j'ai
pas 20 ans moi j'ai 65 je vous dis juste
les mecs que vous êtes tous des bars
de fer voilà et je sais que vous pensez
qu'à une chose c'est mettre de côté pour
aller pour aller vous barrer là-bas
[Rires]
oui non on attend que ça